[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the potter family
lord voldemort and the question that i'm
sure has struck the minds of potterheads
worldwide
at some points or another that question
is why didn't
lily potter apparate away from godric's
hollow with baby harry
during the attack from voldemort the
attack on the potter residence which
occurred on october 31st
1981 claimed the lives of both of
harry's parents
james who died protecting his family and
lily
who sacrificed herself to save harry the
attack
came after sybil trelawny who was
interviewing for a position at hogwarts
had a vision of the prophecy the same
prophecy
that would uproot the wizarding world
the one with the power to vanquish the
dark lord approaches
born to those who have thrice to find
him born as the seventh month dies
and the dark lord will mark him as his
equal but he will have power the dark
lord
knows not and either must die at the end
of the other
for neither can live while the other
survives the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord
will be born as the seventh month dies
snape who was a death eater at the time
overheard trolone's prediction
and relayed the info to voldemort the
prophecy threatened voldemort's position
and so he knew that he would need to
take action
upon realizing that they were in danger
the potters went into hiding
hoping to put in place as many
preventative measures as reasonably
possible
they ended up finding sanctuary in the
town of godric's hollow
and they were protected by the fidelius
charm the fidelius charm is an
incredibly powerful piece of magic
that conceals a secret inside of a
chosen secret keeper's soul
and in this instance the secret was the
potter's location the only hole in their
plan
was the man that they had chosen as
secret keeper pisa
pettigrew a sniveling excuse for a man
pettigrew ended up changing sides
and gave the location of the potters to
voldemort leaving them wide open
to his attack on one unassuming october
day
voldemort struck and it was truly a day
that would change the course of history
when he entered their home james potter
was the first to get in his way
the first line of defense protecting
lily and harry
however james had one very big problem
he didn't have his wand on him
the potters were caught completely off
guard because they never suspected
that their location would be revealed
and that they would be betrayed by their
secret keeper
because he didn't have his wand he was
no match for voldemort
though i suspect that even with it
voldemort would have made quick work of
him
james was a talented wizard but not even
close to level of the dark lord
from there voldemort began making his
way toward lily and baby harry
still dead set on his goal of killing
the boy at this point
as far as the real storyline goes
voldemort then advances
towards the room containing both lily
and baby harry
when he entered the room voldemort did
something quite unexpected
offering lily a chance to step aside
this was not a luxury that was offered
to james
but at the end of the day it was only
really harry that he wanted
he explained that if she simply stepped
away and let him have harry
that he would spare her life this was at
the request of severus snape
who loved lily and likely deeply
regretted relaying the prophecy to
voldemort
unsurprisingly however lily did not
allow voldemort to have her son
and refused this led to voldemort
murdering her
with the killing curse voldemort then
turned his wand on harry
and let out one more of arakadavra
hoping to put an end to the potter
family once and for all
however thanks to lily's loving
sacrifice the curse rebounded
killing voldemort for a time and saving
baby harry so that's how things actually
transpired
but what i want to look at is why lily
didn't just operate with harry
vacating the potter residence entirely
when james told lily to take harry and
run
there was undoubtedly a sort of unspoken
understanding
that he would die so why didn't lily
take this opportunity
to escape voldemort was over the
threshold as james came sprinting down
the hall
it was easy too easy he had not even
picked up his wand
lily take harry and go it's him go
run i'll hold him off hold him off
without a wand in his hand
he laughed before casting the curse
avada kadavra
for those unaware apparition is of
course a magical means of transportation
akin to teleportation where the user
instantly travels from one location to
another
it's an advanced magical ability but
lily potter was an advanced witch
and more than capable to begin to answer
this question
we can start by looking at the deathly
hallows when the trio travel from shell
cottage to gringotts
all three of them glanced back at shell
cottage lying dark and silent
under the fading stars then turned and
began to walk toward the point
just beyond the boundary wall where the
fidelius charm
stopped working and they would be able
to disapperate
what we can derive from this passage is
that apparition isn't possible
when the fidelius charm is at play a
charm which of course
was present at the potter cottage
furthermore in the half blood prince
dumbledore explains to harry that it's
quite common for wizarding homes to be
outfitted with an anti-apparition charm
in order to keep out unwanted guests
professor
why couldn't we just operate directly
into your old colleague's house
because it would be quite as rude as
kicking down the front door said
dumbledore courtesy dictates that we
offer fellow wizards the opportunity of
denying us entry
in any case most wizarding dwellings are
magically protected
from unwanted apparatus at hogwarts for
instance
you can't operate anywhere inside the
buildings or grounds said harry quickly
hermione granger told me so as we can
see lily potter didn't operate for a
number of reasons
the fidelius charm meant that apparition
was entirely impossible
and the fact that most wizarding homes
were outfitted with anti-apparition
charms
made it entirely improbable living under
the imminent threat of lord voldemort
approaching
i'm more than willing to bet that an
anti-apparition charm was placed
on the potter cottage but wait there's
one more huge reason
that lily wasn't able to apparate she
didn't have her wand
in the deathly hallows voldemort
recounts that neither james nor lily
had their ones when he killed them he
was over the threshold as james came
sprinting into the hall
it was easy too easy he had not even
picked up his wand
lily take harry and go it's him go
run i'll hold him off hold him off
without a wand in his hand
he laughed before casting the curse
avada
he climbed the steps listening with
faint amusement to her attempts to
barricade herself in
she had no wand upon her either in harry
potter oneless magic
is certainly possible but the more
complicated the spell the more likely it
is that the witch or wizard
will require a wand to channel said
magic
apparition is no easy feat in fact most
witches and wizards
can't do it at all so i'm willing to bet
that lily potter not having her wand
is just another contributing factor as
to why she would be unable
to operate so as you can see there are
many reasons why lily potter didn't
apparate
and they all seem to be pretty
reasonable explanations
did you guys ever think about this let
me know in the comment section
below until next time remember we are
only as strong as we are united
as weak as we are divided
[Music]
you